trois détenus dans des cellules de 9 m²
des taux d'occupation qui atteignent les
200 % nos prisons débordent et le nombre
de détenus a encore franchi un nouveau
cap le 1er janvier 2024 alors quelles
sont les raisons de la surpopulation
carcérale est-ce un mal propre à la
France et surtout pouvons-nous y
remédier par exemple en créant de
nouvelles places de
prison le 1er janvier 2024 il y avait
75677 personnes dans les prisons
françaises problème il n'y a pas autant
de place que de détenus en moyenne 123
détenus pour 100 place preuve que le
problème ne date pas d'hier pour la
troisème fois en 10 ans cette situation
a valu à la France d'être épinglée par
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
en juillet 2023 sauf en 2020 en raison
de la pandémie de covid-19 la densité
carcérale a augmenté depuis 10 ans très
clairement la surpopulation carcérale ne
s'explique pas par l'augmentation de la
délinquence quand on compare les
chiffres dans les années 80 et
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que le
nombre d'infractions n'a pas augmenté
quand on essaie de trouver les les
véritables raisons de cette augmentation
de la population carcérale c'est
réellement dans la politique pénale
qu'il faut la trouver dans un
durcissement de la répression pénale à
titre de comparaison dans les années 80
une peine moyenne était autour de 5 ou 6
mois nous sommes aujourd'hui à 10 ou 11
mois autre raison de la surpopulation
carcérale l'usage important de la
comparition immédiate un argument que
cite la Cour des comptes dans son
rapport d'octobe 2023 quand on entre
dans une salle de compartion immédiate
on a 70 % de chances de finir en
détention à la fin de la journée c'est
fois plus de risque d'incarcération que
de dans n'importe quelle autre audience
pénale on se rend compte que c'est le
flux principal finalement
d'incarcération cette évolution elle
s'explique aussi par des choix
politiques fait lors des trois derniers
qu'inen il y a un deuxième facteur lié à
la réforme de la justice de 2021 où en
fait ont été supprimés des des crédit de
réduction de peine en disant maintenant
ça doit se mériter et on espérait par
une autre mesure c'est-à-dire des
libérations conditionnell automatique
elle pour le coup à 3 mois de la fin de
peine on espérait comme ça fluidifier un
peu le le le nombre de détenus et ça n'a
pas été le cas 11 prisons ont
aujourd'hui des taux d'occupation qui
dépassent les 200 %. la France est le 3è
pays européen où la population carcérale
est la plus importante quand nous
affichons un taux d'occupation de 115 %
la médiane européenne est elle à 88 % à
titre de pure comparaison parce qu'on
aime souvent se comparer à l'Allemagne
sur le plan social sur le plan
économique en Allemagne on compte 78
personnes détenues pour 100 plac en
France on est donc à 115 ou 120 mais ça
ne veut pas dire que les gouvernements
successifs n'ont rien fait pour remédier
à la surpopulation carcérale la loi du
23 mars 2019 autorise les des
aménagements de peinees pour des peines
d'un an contre 2 ans auparavant elle
interdit également l'emprisonnement pour
les peines de moins d'un mois donc on
voit qu'il y a quand même cette volonté
de rendre si vous voulez la prison comme
le dernier recours dans un parcours de
délinquence ces mesures là on le voit
fonctionnent assez peu la Cour des
comptes note même l'échec de toutes les
mesures de régulation mise en place
depuis 20 ans le nombre des
incarcérations augmente au même rythme
que les mesures alternatives sans effet
de substitution l'approbation qui évite
la prison ferme ne semble pas non plus
être la solution magique le Conseil
européen note d'ailleurs un lien entre
les taux d'incarcération et de probation
autre mesure à l'effet illimité même si
ça peut paraître contreintuitif la
création de nouvelles places de prison
en 2018 Emmanuel Macron annonce le plan
15000 la création de 15000 nouvelles
places de prison d'ici à 2027 mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que une
prison ça met très longtemps à se
construire que l'on a souvent entre le
moment où on décide d'en construire une
et le moment où elle va sortir de terre
et être opérationnelle il peut se passer
10 ans et pendant ces 10 ans si vous
voulez la société évolue et la
délinquence évolue les rapports
parlementaires qui ont pu être publiés
l'année au mois de de mai 2022 estimit
déjà que le plan 15000 était était était
inopérant plus on construit plus on
rempli c'est une écoation qui n'a jamais
été démentie depuis près de 200 ans on a
construit 20 5000 places de prison
depuis
1987 et on a incarcéré autant de
nouvelles personnes détenues depuis mais
alors que peut faire la France selon
certains il faudrait diminuer l'usage de
la comparitiontion immédiate ou de la
détention provisoire et pour juger et
enfermer différemment tout en
garantissant la sécurité nationale
davantage d'études sont nécessaires ça
passera par d'abord une une étude une
étude plus fine de ce qu'est de ce
qu'est la criminologie et je pense qu'on
a un déficit en matière de criminologie
ça passera aussi par une vraie
évaluation justement des politiques
d'aménagement peine parce qu'aujourd'hui
finalement il n'y a jamais eu
d'évaluation et quand on parle
d'évaluation de ces politiques
d'aménagement de peine c'est c'est
autour de l'efficacité par rapport à la
récidive et la et la
[Musique]
réitération